صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء رئيس القمه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط امين
عام جامعه الدول العربيه
السيدات والساده يطيب لي ان اعرب عن خالص
الشكر وعظيم الامتنان الى خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز والى
حكومه المملكه على كرم الضيافه وحفاوه
الاستقبال منذ ان وقعت اقدامنا هذه الارض
الطيبه المباركه واهنئكم على توليكم رساله
رئاسه القمه كما تقدم بالشكر والتقدير
لفخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون لما بذله
من جهود دعوبا ومميزه خلال راسه فتره
الدوره السابقه
انه لمن دواعي اهتزازنا بالقوه العربيه
المتابعه الدائمه لجامعه الدول العربيه
على مستوى القمه وعبر كل هياكل الجامعه
للاوضاع في ليبيا والتي تتجلى في جمله
القرارات المتخذه بشان الاوضاع في ليبيا
على مر السنوات الاثنى عشر الاخيره وهو ما
يجعلنا نطمح الى دور اوسع واوضح للجامعه
العربيه من خلال دعم جهود ودور الاتحاد
الافريقي والامم المتحده في تحقيق
المصالحه الوطنيه الشامله وانجاز
الاستحقاق الانتخابي بانتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسيه خلال العام الحالي عشرين 23 ووضع
ترتيبات ماليه لاداره الايرادات
والمصروفات للدوله الليبيه بملكيه وطنيه
خالصه وفي اطار الجهود المبذوله لتوطيد
الاستقرار والامن يواصل المجلس الرئاسي
لاشراف بالتنسيق مع بعثه الامم المتحده في
ليبيا على عمل لجنه خمسه زائد خمسه لتوحيد
المؤسسه العسكريه وتستمر على الصعيد
السياسي مساعينا الجاده بالتعاون والتنسيق
مع الاطراف المحليه وبعثت الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا التي من ضمنها دعم خطوات
التي يقوم بها مجلسين نواب والدوله من
خلال لجنه سته زائد سته التي اوكل لها
المجلس التوافق حول القوانين الانتخابيه
السيدات والساده اننا في ليبيا ندعم كل
الجهود الفرديه والجماعيه لتحقيق التضامن
العربي وراء بالصدع ونبذ الخلافات بين
بلداننا وفي هذا الصدد نثني على جهود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه في لم
الشمل العربي الذي ادى الى انعقاد هذه
القمه بكامل اعضائها كما نبارك ونؤيد
جهودها الهادفه للوصول الى حل شامل
مقبول ومستدام في اليمن الشقيق ينهي
الازمه بالتوافق بين الحكومه الشرعيه
والحوثيين كما اننا نبدي استعدادنا الى
الانخراط في الجهود المبذوله في حل الازمه
السودانيه بما يؤدي الى انهاء الاقتتال
بين الاخوه وبما يحفظ الاستقرار في
منطقتنا اصحاب جلاله والفخامه والسمو من
خلال هذا المنبر ندعو اشقائنا العرب لتبني
موقف موحد اتجاه الاوضاع في ليبيا وعلى
راسها رحيل كافه المرتزقه والمقاتلين
الاجانب والقوات الاجنبيه عن الاراضي
الليبيه ووقف التدخلات السلبيه وغير
البناعه ودعم المسار الديمقراطي والتداول
السلمي للسلطه كما نجدد تاكيدنا على ضروره
توظيف اي حوار لاستكمال تنفيذ خارطه
الطريق المنبثقه عن الحوار السياسي وتحقيق
هدفها الى تعزيز الشرعيه السياسيه
الانتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه والابتعاد عن
كل ما مشان زياده الانقسامات في ليبيا
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والصمون شعبكم
الشقيق في ليبيا ارتبط وجدانيا بقضيه
العرب المركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه منذ
اللحظه التي نهض فيها الشعب الفلسطيني
والشعوب العربيه لمقاومه مشاريع الاستيطان
في اراضي فلسطين التاريخيه واننا ندعو في
هذا الاطار الى تنفيذ كافه قرارات جامعه
العربيه الداعيه الى دعم صمود وحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني وحقه في اقامه دولته المستقله
وفق قرارات الامم المتحده ذات الصله ويظل
موقف دوله ليبيا ثابتا وراسخا في دعم شعب
الفلسطيني ومسانده نضاله وكفاحه حتى ينال
حقوقه المشروعه ورفض اي تغيير على الوضع
القانوني لمدينه القدس بالاضافه الى عدم
الاعتراف باي قرارات احاديه تؤدي لعرقل
شهود السلام كما ما يتعرض له المسجد
الاقصى من اقتحامات وتعديات تقبل اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو واصحاب المعالي
والسعاده والسيدات والساده تمنياتي لكم
بموفور الصحه والعافيه والسداد ولبلداننا
الشقيقه التقدم والازدهار ولاخواننا في
السعوديه التقدير والامتنان في ظل قياده
خادم الحرمين الشريفين ووريعاده صاحب
السمو الملكي رئيس المجلس الوزراء الامير
محمد بن سلمان اشكركم والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات